[Music]
marion tallahassee florida starts off
this hour hey mary what's up
hi how are you thank you for taking my
call my pleasure how can we help honor
it's an honor to speak with you you too
what's up
well i have a question i
have an inheritance
and
my sister was left out of the will
whoa
i think that there's been some conflict
along the years that i don't think that
got resolved
one was
her significant other um and
it just never got resolved and some
things had been
said along the way my mom was very uh
strong-willed and very independent my
dad passed away 25 years ago so she had
to be there so your mom was not in
relationship with your sister
and chose to not leave her anything as a
result
exactly well that sounds reasonable
oh wow okay
well why would your mom leave something
to somebody that doesn't speak to her
yeah well
she tried to uh my sister tried to with
my mom but my mom had just had
enough
right she'd had enough she cut her off
right in life and in death
right
you know you know the old-fashioned
saying for that is you're dead to me you
ever heard that
yes yeah sometimes teenagers use it they
don't know what they're talking about
but that's where it comes from
so mary do you feel guilty is that why
you're calling
at first i did but then um i kind of got
i got shut down basically she she said
are you going to you know split this
with me just i want to know so if you're
not that means you agree with
with
mom i said i didn't say that we're not
taking that guild trip no thank you
that's on her
yeah i kind of i kind of with your mom i
don't like your sister much
[Laughter]
well so it has been yes because i'm
trying trying to do the main thing but
also at the same time i'm trying to
honor my mom
and i tried to smooth things over and it
it did not work i tried my very best and
now i was your sister's a head case yeah
so i've you know i was like well what do
i do now so it's been uh
you meet you lose your parents you know
to dementia alzheimer's and then you
deal on this and now not talking to me
so i'm like well where do i go because
that's going to cut that rope that's
going to cut that because
you not giving her money is not cutting
the relationship off she is choosing
to cut the relationship off
oh
that makes sense you didn't choose she
chose i'm sorry it hurts though
it does and when when you have a
manipulator trying to manipulate you and
you don't fall for it and they back off
and throw grenades it does hurt i'm so
sorry what was your relationship to your
sister prior to the inheritance
well
i've always wanted more of a
relationship
than what i got and
now when there's money she wants a
relationship
yeah but there's you have to buy a
relationship isn't that called
prostitution
yeah
right
but also at the same time i don't know i
think that there was a lot of uh what do
you call it uh resentment towards me
which i did not know it finally came out
when my mom got sick seven years ago
with them with uh alzheimer's dementia
and it all came out and i'm like what
did i you know what did i do and then
this is the fine final thing you're
going to have to release yourself the
truth is did you really do anything but
wrong mary
no you were you mean to your sister no
did you reach out to her yes did she
reciprocate no
did she call you up after there was
money involved yes only when there was
money involved did she actually reach
out and act like you needed a
relationship with her
right
she did not that's right
she's not really interested in a
relationship with you she's just
interested in money is that wrong am i
wrong
you're spot on that's what the evidence
in this discussion says anyway
but it still hurts
yes because it's your sister it's your
last remaining relative now with your
dad and your mom both gone you've you
know you feel it feels she puts it on
you as if you caused this you didn't
cause any of it
she chose to be resentful to you
because you were actually able to
maintain a relationship with your mother
albeit your mother might be difficult
too it sounded like
but you were able to maintain that
and you weren't being manipulative in
that you were just able to walk a road
your sister couldn't walk with your mom
and so now she's mad at mom and now
she's mad at you and now if you don't
give her money she's mad at you
right
right and i also was told
my mom
destroyed our family
by doing that so i was that was uh
and then i said um
uh mom loved her family don't
don't ever tell me that she left her
family so it was it kind of had built
from there yeah well she's hurt and mad
at you right
right she's a wounded wounded girl but
um
if i thought you giving her money would
make all of this go away and everybody
would be happy and not not weird and you
guys would just be great little sisters
like in some movie or something yeah i
would tell her to share it with her
because it's just stupid money
but money's not the problem here it's
just it's just revealing the problem
right
and so it doesn't we know it's not going
to fix it because let me tell you give
her half the money
okay how long is it set your watch how
long is it for she's pissed off about
something else
true tick tick tick tick oh there it is
yeah
true so that tells us it's not about the
money
it's about the dysfunctional sister so
um
you know uh
you know what i would just say
you you know dr john deloney would say
write her a letter
and then maybe don't send it just get it
out of your system but grieve
the loss of the relationship because it
hurts
and you know you might just set some
boundaries and tell her listen this is
not about money when you and i are
friends again we can talk about stuff
like money but right now i've tried to
have a relationship with you and you
didn't want to have one until there was
money involved so
it's this is on you
you know and so if you want to come hang
out for a dinner anytime i'd love to
have you i'm not mad at you
but as of right now uh no we're not
going to have any financial discussions
or transactions
you know if you ever need any help and
and we're in a good strong relationship
together again i'll try to help you
but
so the other thing i try to remember is
okay i get that mom wasn't the easiest
person but you know this is her
will it's what she wanted to happen
that's why they call it a will this is
what i will to happen i want this to
happen
and that was her will she decided with
her money what she wanted to have happen
to her money
it's not your place to change that
and so i i wouldn't especially in this
situation because it's not going to get
you what you want
but it does hurt
and i'm sorry